le département vous présente terre de
trail
[Musique]
une petite ambiance du matin m'appelle
sur l'un des sites les plus fréquentés
de notre île vous connaissez tous deux
doutent comme ça et c'est le citoyen du
maïdo travail devant moi je m'appelle 2
2 où j'habite dans les eaux y arrive des
fois je te sens d'en bas quand cannot
voir tout le titre est pas loin
66 grand raid misy fallu m'y arrêter
inconnu écoute fait plaisir mais c'est
chouette 110 ha oui bah c'est ça fait
deux ans maintenant c'est nouveau c'est
la caverne d'ali baba qui s'appelle non
c'est la caverne d'ali doudou moi je
suis l'iso jean eschbach
il faut savoir que sur la route du maïdo
ça fait depuis 87 que je suis là
maintenant tout le monde le connaît à
travers doudou parce que j'ai tenu un
restaurant qui a duré quand même 36 ans
avec une belle histoire
je connais l'histoire du maïdo depuis le
début tous les projets qui ont été faits
qui ont été complètement abandonnée et
délaissé sais que j'ai des jeunes de
sépare encore à qui on avait promis
plein de plein de choses mais j'ai ces
enfants qui demain j'ai pas envie que le
maïdo se développe sans eux ça fait que
notre association c'est peut-être
aujourd'hui de mettre en valeur de
certaines choses de le savoir du jean de
la population moi j'aime retrouver des
gens qui exploitent le maïdo mais qui en
même temps développe avec les jeunes du
maïdo avec la population qui met en
valeur parce que c'est dur de voir des
veaux milliers de voitures montées des
milliers de cas remonter avec des
touristes des bateaux troisième tour et
se sentir inutile à ça je pense que la
population a besoin de s'intégrer là
dedans et trouver sa place sans parler
argent mais le fait de dire avant quand
on disait bonjour au bord de la route où
on devait la main tout cela
j'ai envie de leur dire que vous venez
sur un site lohan f se bat pour
l'entretenir ce site
il est propre il est joyeux j'ai vu
l'année dernière il ya des familles des
femmes des mères de famille avec leurs
enfants qui voulait monter pour
encourager au ravitaillement leur mari
mais ils savaient pas ils étaient perdus
dans on avait mis deux trois jeunes qui
les accompagnaient jusqu'au
ravitaillement tout cela ça veut dire
qu'on est présent sur tout le côté
social surtout le côté humain mais là ce
qui me tracasse c'est que le maïdo ce
qu'on vient pique-niqué convient avec
des choses repartez avec ses cigarettes
et un vos mégots et vos classiques et
tous à la cua alors ça c'est le lot de
géraniums c'est de l'eau ce qu'on
appelle d'hydrolats et j'aime bien
mettre ça partout parce que le maillot
avant il faut savoir que sur toute la
route c'était que deschamps géraniums et
aujourd'hui ça se perd et ça se meurt il
n'y a plus trop de chefs de géraniums ça
doit pas être une route un business ça
doit être une route de partage c'est
génial le parking place à fait plaisir
sa vie c'est rien du tout merci écoute à
la prochaine bon courage surtout
convaincant pour moi c'est avec ça
[Musique]
le département vous a présenté terre de
travail